i'm in shock still i i feel like the
female vocalist
award is just so monumental
the women that have gone before me and
won that award
that's who i really should have thanked
now i'm just you know realizing
i completely brain farted on that one um
i was like did i miss anyone oh like all
the women that came before me with this
huge award um thank you
i am so inspired by every single woman
in that category
i'm friends with every nominee in that
category so i know how much we uplift
and support each other in this community
so
it just feels amazing to walk away with
that and to also
you know walk away with musical event
with miranda and kaylee and tanil
and ashley so it's just been like the
the night of the ladies and i hope
that um i don't they haven't announced
entertainer but
you know carrie's got my vote on that
one i want to know why
you said when you were on stage you
never dreamed you never thought you'd
win this trophy
um well i mean miranda's clinched it
like
nine or ten or more years in a row so i
just always this
and you know she deserves it so i just
feel like i never really saw myself
winning this
and it's just such a i feel like when i
when i vote on that award in years past
it's it's for
not the best singer of the bunch because
that's so
objective or subjective but i feel like
that
goes to someone that your peers think
had a massive
monumental year so i am just so humbled
that my nashville
community my industry peeps think that
my year has been
big because part of it has been in 2020
which has been
kind of a show so i feel like
you know someone saying that i had a
good year is so much validation
you have obviously kind of been at odds
with all the mommy shamers and the
ridiculous people online
and that makes me sad because i want to
see hayes and so i'm wondering do you
think that you will get to a point first
of all were you shocked
that there are such entitled people who
feel the need to tell you everything
you're doing is wrong and secondly
secondly do you think there'll come a
point where you feel like you can just
kind of
not care what they're saying and give us
all the joy of seeing
little haze growing up i mean i guess i
shouldn't be shocked because i've had
plenty of
trolls come after me before and i can
definitely
have thick skin when it comes to someone
saying you know my music is terrible
or i'm ruining the sanctity of country
music but for some reason it feels like
an extra betrayal when it's another
mother shaming another mother
and i just feel like we need to all give
each other some grace and i would never
do that and i've learned to be less
judgmental
all around just by being a mom because
it's extremely humbling
and yeah i just think like let's all
love each other and
uh give each other good advice
even if it's unsolicited at least it's
good advice i would just say like
let's do better and not put someone down
that's obviously trying their best